>> IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
OH GOOD. IT IS STLL SHART WEEK
HERE AT COMEDY CENTRAL.
WE ARE DEEP IN IT.
WE ARE SMACK DAB IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE WAKE OF SHART WEEK,
BUT WE'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES
GETTING IN ON THE FUN.
THEBIGLEAD.COM BROUGHT US THE
INTERVIEW OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
KENTUCKY FOOTBALL PLAYER CORY
JOHNSON EXPLAINING HIS WEIGHT
FLUCTUATION.
>> TWO STEAKS AND TWO EXTRA
MEALS, YOU PUT ON 10 POUNDS?
>> I MEAN, I GUESS BECAUSE I
POOP SO MUCH.
I TRY TO POOP, LIKE, FIVE TIMES
A DAY.
>> CORY JOHNSON, YOUR WORDS
SHALL GO DOWN IN SHITSTORY.
SO TO HONOR OF CORY, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS SHART QUOTES.
AN EXAMPLE MIGHT BE WE HAVE
NOTHING TO SMEAR BUT SMEAR
ITSELF OR ONE SMALL FART FOR
MAN, ONE GIANT (BLEEP) FOR
MANKIND. YOU GET THE IDEA HOW
THIS GOES. 60 SECONDS AND GO.
KURT.
>> TURN DOWN FOR PLOP.
>> NICE. JASON.
>> OH, THE PLACES YOU'LL GO.
>> OH NICE, THAT'S ADORABLE.
POINTS.
>> JESSIMAE.
>> OUR FATHER WHO SHART IN
HEAVEN.
>> NICE.
A VERY FAMOUS QUOTE.
POINTS.
KURT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO NEED A BIGGER
BUTT.
>> JASON.
>> ( BLEEP ) HAPPENS.
>> YES, POINTS.
I MEAN, IT'S RIGHT THERE.
IT WAS RIGHT THERE.
THAT WAS FROM THE MOVIE "FOREST
DUMP."
>> "FOREST DUMP," YES.
>> POINTS. JASON.
>> TO ( BLEEP ) OR NOT TO-- AH,
TOO LATE.
>> JESSIMAE.
>> SHOW ME THE RUNNY!
>> KURT.
>> THAT'S NOT KNIFE.
YOU ( BLEEP ) IN YOUR HAND.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> YEAH.
>> NO!
>> DON'T GIVE ME POINTS! I DON'T
GIVE A (BLEEP)!
>> THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
>> I WILL MOST CERTAINLY NOT
GIVE YOU POINTS, SIR!